first conversations you have are always
about what makes something feel like
Star Wars
this is the most massive production I've
ever worked on
they've outdone themselves in sentences
it makes me feel like I'm on another
planet every other day we're gonna do
incredible location Croatia was the
perfect place to shoot canto bites we're
in this alleyway in Dubrovnik smashing
speeders it's just one of those oh my
gosh what are we doing this is amazing
moments
the other big new world is crates we
shot in Bolivia on the salt flats it's
got his red mineral covered with salt
flakes that gives it a sort of a white
blank canvas
what would a battle on a planet like
that look like
[Music]
we also shot on skellig michael off the
coast of ireland
he's very much the Brecon scaling
shooting eight maybe the wrong thing
feels really nice to put Luke Skywalker
in front of a camera
and turn
all right come on you've never seen
anything like this
there's just this magical feeling that
you get and you're transported to
another world
we are working in pretty high places
dangerous places I think it's worth it
because everything is gorgeous
you
you